they came to see a final goodbye to a
friend a neighbor a man they now call a
martyr Muhammad herzalo was shot by the
Israelis in July his death on Wednesday
delayed but inevitable he died just a
few weeks after his friend this
graveyard has become familiar to many
who watch events elsewhere with a
growing frustration
many people under occupation have the
right to resist look at Ukraine when the
war started there was international
support for Ukraine but here there are
lots of international resolutions at the
U.N that are put away in drawers the U.S
vetoes any resolutions against Israel
there were two funerals in nabulous on
Thursday the second for Muhammad Abu
kashek shot in the abdomen by the
Israeli Army after confrontations
between Palestinians and settlers these
latest deaths the United Nations say
bring the number of Palestinians on the
West Bank killed by the Israelis this
year to 150 the highest figure in 16
years and there's still five weeks of
2022 to go for the Next Generation the
dead become Heroes as a Dean mclough
comes to this gravesite every day for a
month before he barely cared now he sees
a future which he knows could be cut
short
this is the time to fight enough is
enough
we've been under occupation for decades
the rain drove most of those who
gathered away but they will be back
another day at another funeral and
another goodbye Alan Fisher Al Jazeera
Nablus in the occupied West Bank